[Musique]
je suis là il a du blog je vais vous
cuisinez j'ai quitté l'alsace ce matin
pour retrouver l'alsace ici au salon de
l'agriculture sur ce magnifique stand
voilà qui est dit dédié aux filières de
l'agriculture alsacienne et aujourd'hui
on va vous parler d'un produit
emblématique de l'alsace qui me tient
tout particulièrement à coeur il s'agit
de la choucroute
on va s'approcher du stand de la maison
de la choucroute maison le pic pour
demander ce cadeau au menu du jour
alors aujourd'hui nous avons un hot dog
alsacien est une saucisse avec du sel
végétal accompagné de choucroute bio
iger p mais nous avons la pasta choucas
et de la choucroute traditionnel mélange
avec de la crème des lardons et
l'espagne cela les pattes alsacienne et
la transition c'est l'alsace la
gastronomie alsacienne
les traditions alsaciennes mais là je
compte inviter les jours de fête sont la
choucroute
elle est connue en tout le territoire
français
c'est important de rld est de légumes en
avant parce que c'est un légume qui
coûtent pas cher qui est très bon pour
la santé
la choucroute d'alsace c'est un produit
simple comme on disait
grâce à la fermentation elle est riche
en vitamine c
riche en fibres et du coup effectivement
détox parce que ça aide effectivement là
à la digestion
on est à nouveau sur l'espace ter alsace
où les chefs des collèges alsaciens
régale les visiteurs tous les jours avec
des recettes qui valorisent nos produits
alsaciens et là on va rencontrer
catherine qui est en train de faire une
recette à base de choucroute et vous
verrez qu'elle fait sortir ce produit de
son carcan parce qu'on a l'habitude de
manger la choucroute de manière
traditionnelle avec sa corde de
charcuterie et on peut aussi la déguster
autrement et est ce qu'elle va nous
montrer en train de faire des nems
alsacien c'est des galettes de riz qu'on
laisse tremper quelques secondes un peu
dans l'eau pour les rameaux l'iton mais
la choucroute et puis c'est comme un
homme pour l'agrémenter encore heures
avec des lardons ça peut être
sympathique aussi
hier de réutiliser des restes de
choucroute et pour le lentilles
gaspillage choucroute on la propose dans
les collèges aux six élèves aiment bien
quand on retravaille le produit du coup
et qu'on leur explique que ce qu'on
avait travaillé comme produit puis qu'on
leur sert le lendemain du coup il ne
sort pas